you also do this character uh bobby
bottle service yes
and you uh you made you made an audition
tape
or bobby bottle service made an audition
tape for jersey shore and i think you
brought that yes
let's take a look oh excuse me you call
me in the middle of putting
vaseline on my lips to keep them very
kissable
i mean as you know is addition to bobby
bottle service i'm a fierce competitor
and that's why i'm perfect for jersey
shore because i will win
season two and i will take the money
with those earnings and buy cool stuff
like a for my grandmother for example in
addition to
a gold jet ski that she could drive open
to see my future children like rest in
peace
and i would say also i would buy myself
something cool
like new uh calf muscles
he's very likable i like bobby he's a
likable guy
how did you what was your method how did
you come up with
bobby bottle service uh it it came about
uh just
living in l.a there's a lot of beautiful
women and not really knowing how to talk
to them and
and realizing that uh guys always hit on
those girls and the guys that are always
hitting on those girls
if you make fun of them then girls sort
of identify
with you so i would just be like no
excuse me but like do you date me
like oh like because i would like to
take you on an ideal date
like first like we would go swimming
with the dolphins
like preferably dan marino
and then i would like cook you breakfast
like
like an omelette with like gold cheese
cause like i care about
food
and then the catchphrase is just sending
me i'm like um excuse me do you date me
i don't know why yeah always speaking
and the thing is you came up with bobby
bottle stores before jersey shore yes
you were doing this character before
jersey shore came along yeah and then
jersey shore came out and i was like
these guys are doing broader versions of
this character than me
i know you thought you were doing the
most cartoonish version of this
character
no they're real people much more who've
got you beat now
is this why you started doing stand-up
in college yeah correct yeah i did uh
i did this thing my freshman year uh
called the funniest act on campus
uh and it wasn't presumptuous no
pressure there yeah yeah that's great
so i was like i'm funny like i was my
friends laugh at me and
in retrospect i was like no we were like
smoking aspirin and dancing the nba jam
song like we thought
just about everything was pretty funny
so uh
so i was like my whole bit was i was
gonna get on stage and be like god i
thought i was gonna be so nervous but
i'm actually totally relaxed
and then i was gonna pee my pants and
that was like and then i'll just like
riff yeah um
and i had one joke i had my the first
joke i ever wrote so you you were
okay i'm sorry let me hear the joke um
it's uh
the joke was um um my girlfriend and my
mom are wearing the same perfume
uh which is kind of bugging me out
because all of a sudden i'm totally
attracted to my girlfriend
[Laughter]
that's a great joke yo that's a good
joke it's like a joke
so so uh so wait a minute so your act
was you go out there
i was gonna piss my pants you go out
there and you say i'm totally calm i
thought i'd be nervous but i'm totally
calm and then suddenly
uh wet your pants yes but how are you
going to do that so i had a
i was the plan was to have a water
balloon and a pin
and i was gonna pop the pop the water
balloon and then it was like i don't
know it would have
ended up looking more like my water was
breaking or something like that
um it's just all at once yeah yeah all
this water yeah that would have been his
bladder burst yeah
so but i got nerve i was actually quite
nervous before the show
um and so i got like a little drunk and
then i showed up at the show and i
didn't have
uh the water balloon or the pin so i'm
rummaging around backstage
uh and i find you didn't bring the only
two things you needed
to make your one joke work yeah yeah i
love that yeah not the most responsible
uh in the biz so i um so i find a
sandwich bag
uh and i take out the sandwich and i
fill it with water but there's still
like
flecks of like wheat bread floating
around inside
and um and i grab a pen and i get on
stage and i'm going to stand for is that
if i stand for that
god i thought i was going to be so
nervous but i'm actually totally relaxed
it just looked like it just looked like
i was like
furiously masturbating which is
basically what i've been doing on stage
ever since
that's how you handle your nerves yeah
it makes sense
my nerves